in the World of Sports One name stands
out not just for his Mastery of one game
but for his incredible versatility
across a range of disciplines
meet Magnus Carlson the ultimate athlete
Magnus Carlson is not just a chess
player he's a chess champion often
referred to as the Mozart of chess
his unparalleled skills have earned him
the title of world chess champion
in this video you are going to witness
him playing different sports and other
activities that probably you have not
seen before
so fasten up your seatbelt and enjoy the
video
[Music]
he's gonna
on remarks Set Go
oh
wow
[Music]
is
laurito
Carolina
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on your station
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh my God